have you watched squid game then yeah i
have i did i watched it again all in one
night because i couldn't take a break me
too yeah and i thought it was very good
i thought it was a very solid show and i
liked it a lot of course there are
things that i wasn't
super into but overall i liked it good
yeah it definitely wasn't the perfect
show but really good yeah
yeah
what i find interesting about the whole
squid game like getting mainstream stuff
now is i've seen so many debates about
the subs versus dub in in the mainstream
now
and it's so surreal right i mean some of
the the dubbing and true game was i i
keep getting recommending clips of some
of the dub clips and squid game and i'm
just like how are people watching this
right now because i think i think i
can't remember i think i saw it on like
philip defranco where he there was a
metric of how many people watched it
dubbed i think it was like 60 or like 69
people more people watch the dogs
because people people just on netflix
people just
when you do it if you've got your
language sent to english it's just
automatically yeah so a lot of people
don't want to then flip i think as well
for some countries like the the original
korean uh like voices just weren't
available what yeah because like i
remember my sister was telling me uh in
australia there was no option other than
the english dub what like you have to
watch in an english style but she's like
what the [ __ ] i don't want to watch in
english
yeah so i think it also depends on the
the country as well i mean which is a
bit weird it's interesting because i
actually i've watched netflix shows with
the dub when they aren't originally like
when it's a different language other
than english i've watched english
english dubs on netflix that i didn't
think were terrible but that
that was something special
like half the actors are speaking in a
different like type of english yeah like
i think half the voice actors are
americans and the other half like
british the old woman just doesn't sound
like an old woman you know that should
be like the first thing that you you try
and do to like at least give a little
bit of effort to not sound like a 25
year old yeah from the clips i've seen
it definitely gives you the impression
that none of the dubbed voice actors
knew how big this was going to be
anyone involved and i don't think even
netflix knew how this how big this was
going to be
um and you can definitely see it
parent yeah because like yeah i i don't
know
maybe it's just because we're in the
anime community but for me especially
when it comes to live action i can't
imagine watching live action in anything
but the original language is
although it is also a guilty pleasure of
mine like every now and then i watch
like a live-action hollywood film with
the japanese dub it's oh my god it's why
joey why so funny it is funny
and even when they get like top voice
actors in like the anime sphere to like
voice over like
vin diesel and [ __ ] fast and furious
i'm just like
it's so weird it's so weird to hear a
different voice that's not vin diesel's
coming out of vin diesel's mouth yeah
it's very funny my curiosity i mean
luckily you should it's really funny i
mean luckily in japan normally all the
movies are in subbed in the cinema yeah
yeah yeah thank you because i can watch
them
it's all the ones that make it the dvd
that are not yeah dvd they have an
option yeah thank god thank god thank
you trevan and seriously i can actually
enjoy going to the cinema it is weird
watching like japanese dubs of like uh
western cartoons though that is weird
like oh like simpsons yeah simpson's
like hearing is japanese rick and morty
as well that was so surreal but it's so
weird that's when i can like kind of get
behind it because
it's it's it's it actually suits it a
lot in a lot of the scenes like they
they like whoever voices rick [ __ ]
blew it out of the park yeah
i want to go listen to this now it's not
bad
okay okay it's this is like the uh being
on the other side of things where it's
like oh no not all dubs are bad even if
it's like originally in english foreign
[Music]
yeah conor in russian trash tasting like
he's like he sounds like he wrestles
bears for a living
i really really am envious of that man
so have you had like time to watch
anything else in your schedule or is it
just like just random stuff random stuff
um recently i've been i got really into
like um it's a super obscure uh like
yakuza film series called um
i know what it's called in english um
battles without honor and or humanity
i need to figure out what the name
sounds like that is that is the most
google translated title i've ever heard
you find out the name of it i wish i
could look it up so what's the plot of
these movies um it's a really long plot
uh it's just about this one this one guy
and his entire experience from start to
finish uh entering the the yakuza family
and it's it's just i can't explain why i
like it it's just kind of cool and like
a lot of the sound clips are just really
iconic the music is really iconic you'll
hear it sampled a lot in japanese rap
it's just really neat and there's a lot
of blood um it was one of the like most
prominent i think yakuza films made in
japan there's five of them i haven't
watched the last one um but i've been
slowly working through them i found them
on amazon with english subtitles there
was only one copy in the world and i got
it
oh wow so it wasn't even streamed it was
like physical media holy [ __ ] that's how
you know that's how you know it's like
underground oh gee yeah i was just i was
recommending how did you find it i was
recommended it by a friend who really
likes japanese movies and i was like
ah i should give this i should check it
out um and i really i really like when
was the last time you bought physical
media knows brexit oh yeah you're you're
always easy like you've bought it to
watch it yeah
you've watched you've you've actually
put it in you've put it in alright i
don't have a dvd player yeah
no but uh playstation works just fine
interestingly yeah i can't remember the
last time i've i brought like a dvd or a
blu-ray that i actually watched yeah
right i've brought i've even bought like
anime blu-rays and dvds but just like
that's just so i can own them physically
even
i'm putting that [ __ ] in you know how
annoying it is getting out going bending
down putting it in [ __ ] do you mention
it
knees yeah i'm an old man now you know
oh sorry i'm a child now but i was an
old man one time and that that was very
difficult too you're an old man stuck in
a childhood man
i i don't i just want to do everything
digitally it's so much easier oh yeah
i mean i mean that's why it's become
that's why you call it dying medium yeah
that's that's why you like
i mean
forget dvds you don't watch anything
that's not on netflix now you know what
you know what sucks is that uh you know
everything good is on like hulu and hbo
and i'm like we don't have that [ __ ] how
do we how do i it's so unfair i'm like i
don't know how to do this please help me
i want hbo everything seems to be on hbo
um oh i mean all a lot of the good shows
a lot i say i say like a lot of the
critically acclaimed shows seem to be on
hbo yeah and you can't get it outside of
america is this where you can within a
sponsorship perhaps actually
a funny thing like a lot of a lot of hbo
shows and a lot of tv shows are
available on youtube to buy right well
i've noticed like
yeah yeah because i've watched schnobl
uh and i watched that
on youtube i watched on amazon prime oh
it's not amazon prime here yeah what's
the name of the product okay but that's
probably like the last amazing
live-action tv show that i've like
probably got into yeah i love that
[ __ ] amazing
wow
you guys just realize sometimes how
things have developed with like anime
and japanese culture in general because
i remember a time when i was younger and
i had to beg mama mori to drive me 40
minutes to the only small anime store
in our state i mean the fact that you
even had an anime story yeah yeah you'll
probably just show that
listen pocky was six dollars and i
remember saving up all what little
allowance i could spray
it was kind of becoming more globalized
the internet was kind of kicking into
full force
uh and yeah even back then it was like
you couldn't get anything by nothing
yeah you didn't live through the dog no
all i could get was like the worst i had
to deal with was like yu-gi-oh gx
espanol part one that was like yeah yeah
that was like the worst i had to deal
with but i could still get it like i
could get it
no i mean
we could also get it as well it just was
a lot harder to find you know it's we
had to put more work into it other than
just streaming i feel like streaming
made anime just like kind of kind of
like you made anime [ __ ] way more
accessible because even back in my day
i still bought dvds whenever i could
right but then once streaming became a
thing i just stopped buying dvds at all
um and yeah it is certainly weird to see
anime become way more [ __ ] popular
nowadays even though none of us watch it
anymore
right joey
the more the more popular anime has
become the less i've watched like
symbiotic you watch as much anime now
kelly i mean to be honest i feel like
all the anime i'm really interested in
is older stuff that i get recommended
for example kaiji and baki i've been
really into
hell yeah
no i've been sl that is the only one
that i have been slowly watching because
i don't want it to end so i've been like
day by day watching an episode nice it's
so good i love that i still need to
watch the anime what what part do you
want if i'm allowed to ask um let's see
what part did we stop off at um let me
think because i've been watching with a
friend who is also a big fan
and we've been watching like at the same
time like overseas completely separated
from each other um let me see which part
were we at what was the last thing that
happened yeah it was the most iconic
thing that happened
in every episode
i think i think baki officially
challenged um his father i think was the
last thing that happened that i saw i'm
like trying to happen like ten times
yeah
maybe
do you realize how little that narrows
it down
in the new season
i have yeah i have two oh okay you're
pretty far then yeah when i started
watching uh baki i actually didn't um i
challenged myself and i didn't watch it
with english subtitles i watched it
completely japanese with japanese only
subtitles and i did not figure out that
baki's dad was who he
is on the subtitles i felt so ashamed i
was like wow so many three years
self-study japanese and i can't even
figure that out
i feel you i feel you
because sometimes like
have you has like
do you watch all anime unsubs now then
or do you watch like some sub some
unsubbed ah you know it depends usually
what i'll do is if it's one that i've
seen before i'll watch it without
subtitles
um but i mean i do watch it with
subtitles but they're japanese subtitles
so i at least get the kanji to like help
me out if i can't really hear how
something comes from
yeah do if if there's like something you
don't understand you like rewind as well
and like just to see if you sound like a
nightmare it is a nightmare yeah i mean
that's how you learn that's how you like
you're not watching you're not watching
it in the same way that you're watching
to enjoy anymore it is a learning
experience study material yeah it is
study material i mean i mean in terms of
studying material i can think of worse
study material than anime yeah but uh
for sure it's it's the sacrifice you
have to make i guess well that's why you
got to like use like a series you've
already seen and like are familiar
when i was with i was hanging out with
some japanese friends and everyone was
watching kaiji and i watched it too and
of course there were no english
subtitles so i was watching and i recall
going home and going on wikipedia and
looking up what happened
there are some shows that are easier to
follow than others i can barely follow
like the rules of what have is happening
in kaiji in english yeah let alone in
another language
yeah i mean those peppa pig plot lines
man those things are [ __ ] complex man
oh honestly you laugh but yeah i i took
i took ladybeard's advice and i started
watching peppa pig in japanese yeah and
i i could tell my japanese was improving
by how much of peppa pig i could
understand
and then like it got to a point where i
could understand 80 80 to 90 off peppa
pig and i was like that was the first
time i felt holy [ __ ] i'm actually
making [ __ ] progress like thanos with
his hand
this is power
oh [ __ ] peppa pig's a good shot
and then i graduated to normal anime
after that and uh
even then there are some anime you have
to be very selective in the anime you
watch if you want to treat anime as
a study material because some things are
just like
just like so far beyond your level becky
seems like a hard one to choose yeah
because i feel like bucky would be
pretty hard because there's so much
explanation of like
what is happening on screen and like the
backstory and stuff oh trust me i read
the manga and i'm i sometimes i have to
like double take me like what the [ __ ]
does that mean
i'm fluent in this language it doesn't
look like my language yeah it's like
it's like sometimes baki is like a
visual storytelling medium and then
sometimes it's really not you know
sometimes it's a novel yeah exactly
i remember where i was we just left the
prison please don't spoil it for me
please chat please i beg of you don't
spoil it for me we also do fake speech
[Laughter]
because we do we do fake spoilers in my
chat uh so people you can't trust anyone
what anyone's saying so i say guys throw
out some fake spoilers so people who are
putting out real spoilers could be lying
we don't know that's how i protect
myself don't worry bucky's one of those
shows where you could give out a real
spoil and be like i guess that's what
happens
we gave out a bunch last episode
actually yeah we literally just talked
about bucky so it's so good it wasn't
planned at all that we'd mentioned bucky
again
well thank you very much for building on
what we said before please go and watch
that yeah
please
it is now v cheaper approved
i know you guys are here too because i
know i have a lot of i have a lot of
fans of me who literally come to my
stream and say i came here from trash
taste um a lot of deadbeats whose names
i see over and over and over again who
are always there i'm just i'm really
thankful to you guys thank you so much
for bringing me so many cool dead beats
oh you came on man yeah